what's going on guys you know the NBA
playoffs are in full effect baseball
season just started but there's only one
competition that we here at screen
junkies really care about who's gonna
win the summer box off we have an
awesome panel of critics to break down
what the top ten grossing films of the
summer are gonna be first up Kristian
harloff he's from the super popular
schmoes no podcast
she is a film critic for the LA Times LA
Weekly make some noise for Amy Nicholson
he is the host of badass digest with
Devin Faraci it's Devin Faraci so guys
we're breaking down what we think the
top 10 grossing films of the summer are
going to be let's read your list and see
where you stand
first up let's look at Kristen's top 10
got Iron Man at number 1
ballsy choice putting Elysium on the
list next up we have Amy's list also
Iron Man 3 at number 1 but you have the
great gatsby on there putting a lot of
faith in Baz Luhrmann alright looking at
Devin Faraci is top 10 we have some
expected choices Man of Steel monsters
you but he also included the lovable
Smurfs finally we have my list the
correct list 100% guaranteed so we can
all agree that Iron Man 3 is gonna be
the number one box office movie this
summer why uh you know Iron Man 3 has
the advantage because it's the first
movie the summer so it's gonna play
longer than anything else on any of our
lists
um also it's really great uh and I think
it's exactly what people want out of a
Marvel movie let's get serious for a
second we got to talk star trek to star
trek into darkness Devin and Amy you
guys have it at eight nine nine eight
eight I have it at nine I got it at two
that movie is gonna be high there's no
chance I mean setting aside the fact
that the movies garbage it's not a
popular franchise it's struggle to get
to two hundred million dollars it's
probably gonna struggle again to get
$209 this summer two hundred million
dollars is not pretty Newton top five
the first part of our seeing it I can't
say I haven't seen it yet he hasn't seen
it
because we heard someone say it his
buddy told oh my god I've got I've got a
little bit information oh alright will
that that aside it is going to blow up
it's gonna be one biggest movie this
summer I just think we also don't have
to take consideration placement because
it's in May
it's coming out right before hangover
and fast and furious and I think it's
just not gonna get the legs it needs
that's a power weekend with hangover 3
and fast and furious I think it's crazy
those two films are going head-to-head
in at first yeah so what's the consensus
here who who wins fast or hangover
overall I'm going fast I'm going fast
too I think it lends itself more to
repeat viewings I'm gonna go fast six
bit all the way this is such a geek
cluttered summer that I think some of
these geek films on our lists are gonna
have to get pushed I understand that I'm
going with Elysium and I'm going with
Wolverine and I don't think those two
are gonna do anything I think they're
gonna be the two that fall you have a
Paul fake lead with our director of
bridesmaids coming back into the game
with the Melissa McCarthy comedy that's
got to be at number 10 which is where
you put it to so I'll give you Elysium
maybe but there's no way Wolverine of
the fact that what mangle has done just
in the trailers to get rid of that last
piece of garbage that came out the
trailers Wolverines crying the whole
time I have said he is a brink that's
what America really is looking for right
now is the whiniest emo version of
Wolverine what about the part when he's
running up the thing I knew an
old-school snick the snick beast Nick
he's going straight up Wolverine style
in the because he's floating on the
train - that looked really great it
looked like a salute is those two scenes
you think there's no way Wolverines
gonna be in the top ten I think because
the last Wolverine movie was like a like
a like a genocide 'old campaign against
moviegoers I think that really hurts
what if you starts singing in this one
five hundred million man of steel Devin
uh your big Man of Steel fan I hear well
I just think um it's gonna be great I
mean I'm a big Zac signer fan unless
like I'm cool to say and I know that
Warner Brothers is so hot for this movie
they think this is the thing and I think
that we finally going to be where
Superman's punching dudes and that's I
think all we've been looking for for
decades now is please Punch something
don't cry and lift up an island that was
the problem with angley's Hulk like what
what is hope supposed to do smash what
did he do have daddy issues so there's
so much with Man of Steel it looks like
they're getting it right and one of the
main things - this is Superman and that
Superboy right we got in 2006 I hope in
20 years we're talking about Michael
Shannon Zod in the same way that we talk
about Terence Stamp son because I love
the Michael Shannon and I'm so excited
to see him blow up well and also I think
you don't think I was saying Wolverines
like the emo Wolverine oh I don't want
to be will read any more oh I can't die
this is Superman he has emotional stuff
going on but it's aspirational emotional
stuff it's all positive it's I am
confused but I'm finding my way
not amount like you know I'm gonna quit
and have to be talked into being
Wolverine again or spider-man 3 dancing
on piano sand yeah that I will go
toe-to-toe on spider-man 3 how that is a
brilliant as the holy in character for
Peter Parker stop it because Peter
Parker don't believe it's a dweebs
version of even trying
that's not spider-man awesome or a
different fighter man you'll want to
break down Topher Grace's venom I don't
know it's a great choice because venom
in the comics so venom Eddie Brock
they're being second oh my god I'm sorry
I'm gonna go for spider-man 3 right now
I'm ready let's go with no one I was
good there's a very successful duo with
an offering the summer Gore Verbinski
Johnny Depp Lone Ranger but only one of
us has Lone Ranger on their list yeah I
mean it's a Johnny Depp in a funny hat
so I think it'll open it nobody's gonna
like it I don't get me wrong it's gonna
make you know 275 million dollars and
not a single person is gonna like it I
agree and I think I fit pops in 7 or
even 6 I wouldn't be surprised at all
because this is a light family movie
that you could take your kids to because
it's so goofy as far as like Johnny Depp
doing the silly faces the whole time I
agree I think that it could definitely
be up there there's there's a movie that
looks like it could be pretty cool could
be kind of lame cific Rim it looks so
cool is jump onto my one of the movies I
want to see the most in the summer not
just how much I think is gonna make
there's a shot in one of these trailers
where one of the robots has a full
submarine in his hand and uses it as a
baseball bat against the monsters sign
me in this is a film that like you're
nine years old in 2013 this is a movie
that she's gonna change your whole life
I have it on five that's kind of an
aspirational position for me because I
want to believe that this summer it
won't just be about like sequels and
franchises we'll get to start one like
audiences will invest money in something
next and something new there are so many
sequels and franchises or and like I was
looking at the the list of sequels it's
like grown-ups to do we want more
grown-up okay that's never brachii I
wouldn't blame not believing it that I
mean you thought that's the worst sequel
that Adam Sandler does why not happy
gilmore we're not feeling Madison I'm
one of those why this one but you got
the Taylor Lautner factor in there I put
myself through the pain and watch the
MTV Movie Awards this year Taylor
Lautner did comedy it was like death for
that reason alone he's a perfect fit for
grownups too
haha guys I want to thank you so much it
was great talking to you about movies we
really geeked out here think you can out
geet these movie critics need your top
ten list in the comment section below
whoever comes closest to the actual top
ten gets two screen junkies t-shirts one
for you one for your mom hey thanks for
watching I'm Hal Rudnick
[Music]